here's a rare sight in Hawaii an adult
albatross on land the lays an albatross
with a wingspan over six feet was born
to soar they're creatures of the wind
living in the sky and there's some
powerful trade winds here in the
Hawaiian Islands to keep them aloft as
long as they want they only return to
land to raise their chicks the chicks
are on a tight schedule in just a few
months they have to develop the strength
stamina and skill to take flight as you
can see this is easier said than done
the closer they get to adulthood the
more pressure there is on them to fly
the fledgling arrow knots turn into the
wind and launch themselves down the
beach death lurks for those who don't
make
the birds that aren't quite air were
they have to plunk down in a gentle surf
where tiger sharks are waiting for them
the young bird tries with all its might
to mimic its parents and get airborne
tiger sharks consume 10 percent of all
the albatross young in this colony this
drama plays out every year and the
Sharks don't always win in fact
sometimes the shark gives the albatross
the inspiration to fly amazing what
knowing you're about to be eaten can do
for your motivation